we recently put out a video on 10
mistakes you should avoid when buying a
new 2019 MacBook Pro and you guys liked
it so much that you asked us to do the
same thing with a new iMac so here it is
here are 10 mistakes you should avoid
when buying a new 2019 iMac 4 mistake
number one do not buy the cheap $1100
iMac option ever no one should buy this
model not even people on a budget
you only get a 1080p display a slow 7
gen dual-core processor slower RAM and
integrated graphics it's basically the
worst choice you can ever make on an
iMac paying an extra 200 dollars gets
you a much more capable machine with a
much better display but even then I
would recommend at least the $1500 4k
iMac because it gets a 6 core processor
and a dedicated graphics card with 4
gigabytes of video memory if you're
looking to buy a cheap iMac for around
$1,100 you should instead buy a
discounted 2017 model like this one
which packs a 4k display quad core
processor and faster graphics for 450
dollars off well link it down below for
mistake number 2 do not buy an iMac with
either a hard drive or a fusion drive
first of all hard drives are incredibly
slow and they're more prone to failure
compared to other storage solutions huge
and drives combine a large hard drive
with a small SSD for example only 24
gigs of SSD for this one terabyte fusion
drive this does speed it up a bit but it
still has the same reliability issues
now an SSD is like a high-speed flash
drive it has no moving parts so it's
more reliable not only that but it's
much faster than any hard drive or
fusion drive and it's only a $100
upgrade for most configurations we'd
recommend getting at least 512 gigs but
even the 256 gig SSD is a much better
choice than the ones here by fusion
drive in worst case scenario you can buy
a portable 1 terabyte hard drive for
just $45 on Amazon for long-term storage
and backups now on to mistake number
three if you're buying a 27-inch model
do not pay for the RAM upgrade
keep it at 8 gigabytes most people know
this already but this iMac features a
user accessible RAM door on the back
allowing you to upgrade the RAM yourself
it's incredibly simple and it doesn't
void your warranty we even made a
step-by-step guide that you can follow
to do it yourself and we'll put a button
on the end of this
oh that links to it there are four RAM
slots and Apple uses up to four the
factory eight gigabytes of RAM and yes
you can add two more sticks and leave
apples RAM in there and it won't cause
any issues the 64 gigabyte upgrade from
Apple costs $1000 while you can
currently buy 64 gigabytes of RAM on
Amazon for only 284 dollars that's seven
hundred and sixteen bucks saved not
including the difference in taxes and
they're not any worse than Apple's RAM
trust me I've been using this RAM on my
iMac for the last two years I'll leave a
link to it down below for mistake number
four some high end users need a ton of
RAM like for virtualization or high in
production work and they mistakenly buy
apples maximum listed 64 gigabytes of
RAM but it's actually not the max the
new 2019 5k iMac actually supports up to
128 gigs of ram with Oh W sees three
party RAM kit and the craziest thing
about it is that it's only nine hundred
dollars that's $100 less than Apple's 64
gigabyte kit we'll also link that down
below this is huge news for people that
really need that much RAM allowing them
to buy an iMac instead of going for the
more expensive iMac pro for mistake
number five the smaller 21 and a half
inch 4k iMac does not have a user
accessible RAM door some people buy this
Mac and buy Ram then realize that it
doesn't have a ram door on the back so
don't make that mistake if you need a
lot of RAM the 27-inch 5k iMac is a much
better value
enough with the RAM let's move on to
mistake number six if you're a
photographer or someone who does
processor heavy work like Logic Pro or
programming do not upgrade the graphics
trust me you don't need it with ran test
in Lightroom and found that upgrading
graphics did literally nothing at all
for performance instead put your money
towards upgrading the RAM we found that
having only 16 gigs of ram limited
performance so get at least a 16 gig kit
and add it to the factory eight for a
total of 24 gigs if you're on a budget
but we recommend getting a 32 gig kit
for a total of 40 gigs to be safe now on
to mistake number seven if you're a
high-end video editor the most important
thing for you is the graphics in the
2019 5k iMac has a brand new Vega 48
graphics option but you have to choose
the highest end 5k iMac configuration
for the option to show up the Vega 40 a
upgrade is 450
but trust us it's worth it and if you
can't afford the Vega 40 option I'd
still recommend the $2,300 5k iMac
because it's the only other one that
comes with a graphics card that has
eight gigs of video memory and that's
very important for video editing and
finally don't feel like you absolutely
have to get the a core processor to get
great performance looking at benchmarks
of these new processors even the
cheapest 3.0 gigahertz six core CPU from
the $1,800 model outperforms the best
processor available in the 2017 iMac
which is what I've been using every day
for the past two years for video editing
and it's been more than fast enough for
the standard 4k editing that we do and
there you have it there are ten mistakes
you should avoid when purchasing a new
2019 iMac you can check out those iMac
videos right there and if this video
helps you out make sure to tap like and
click that circle above to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]